welcome everybody I'm are quickly the
Dean of the school welcome to this very
very beautiful day this is a historic
moment because this is the first time
that the real estate students get to get
wet with everybody else and for me
personally and I think for the
leadership of your program this is a
hugely symbolic moment when the real
estate program joins with all of the
other graduates of Columbia University
at the leading edge of a new generation
of brilliant leaders for the future so
it's it's emotionally technically
legally everything different than it's
ever been before I think it's especially
nice that the history of the leadership
of this program is also with us with
Hank Bell who's in his 2420 second year
in the in in in the program getting
stronger by the minute John Livingston
who was your key leader as you got
underway with this whole new curriculum
and
and is a very important leader in your
programming and in New York City and
therefore in your world vashan
shekhawati who is your uber uber dynamic
leader if anything he's irritatingly
good if he could just turn it down a
little bit it would make it easier for
everybody else fantastic program the
really good news is that I'm not going
to talk to you you have absolutely
brilliant guest speaker but again just
to say this one thing that that when I
started to become dean of the school was
about seven years ago and already at
that moment one of my visions was that
there would be a day that the real
estate program would stand side by side
with all of the other programs in the
university not just within the School of
Architecture but alongside the business
school philosophers the anthropologists
the doctors the lawyers absolutely
everybody else standing proudly at the
very front line of a whole new
generation of Columbia graduates this
required a whole new program to
accomplish a whole new sense of
leadership but also a whole new kind of
student and you really are that new
species and in a certain way as you know
what makes the School of Architecture
planning preservation unique is that we
are not simply the only program in the
world in which almost every specialty
with regard to the built environment is
present but in each and every case we
reorganize the professional expertise in
other words our interest is not simply
how to teach you to be brilliant real
estate developers but to invent whole
new forms of real estate development
this is not a trade school this is a
research university this is about
developing entire new forms of
leadership this means that the whole
school now depends on the new ideas that
are coming from your program already
with the brilliant work for example when
seven of your students went with seven
of the architecture students and became
this dynamic team your program is a in a
whole new place I was lucky enough the
other day to see seven or eight of your
students present their case study
project an amazing team and amazing
presentation
if I was a real victim like running the
planning of the city or making
permissions or doing painting I would
have no chance against this proposal
this was absolutely touch top-notch
financially in terms of presentation in
terms of design it was a seriously
dangerous proposal as befits a
cutting-edge school and what has often
been a dream in the school that the real
estate program be the hardest program in
the school has become a reality and I
really want to thank the students for
having kind of gone through the bumps
that are associated with getting a whole
new program underway and we especially
want to hear from you now your feedback
on how vision and John myself Hank
Danielle and everybody else could
re-energize the program remember that
the thing about degrees is that they're
retroactive the more we improve the
quality of your program the more it will
appear that you graduated from an even
better program so feed your suggestions
and because 10 years from now nobody
will believe that somebody with your
abilities was able to get into the
program and you should just sort of
quietly smile that obviously your
strengths are somewhat secret and point
to the amazing deals that you've done
over the recent years deals that have a
character and a shape quite unlike those
of your predecessors and with a set of
partners quite unlike those that you've
had before anyway warm round of welcome
for vashan chakrabarti an absolutely
brilliant leader of your program
thank you Mark it is to the Dean that we
owe a tremendous amount of gratitude
it's his determination on a daily basis
that made this makes this program better
makes our school better makes our entire
university better so much of what we've
accomplished this year could not have
been possible without the Dean so I just
very much want to thank mark Wiggly good
afternoon graduates families friends
thank you for sharing this great
milestone with us today graduation is so
often misconstrued as a departure a
departure from a school a departure from
a city a departure from a youth that
separates us from our upbringing xand
our families today I'd like deposit that
we're actually not experiencing a
departure but a homecoming a very wet
homecoming but a homecoming to be sure
for me at a personal level this is
without question true you are my first
graduating class and we've been through
very many things together a lots and
lots of highs a couple of small bumps
along the way but you will always be
very special to me I'm very and hold a
special place in my head in my heart as
you're my first class for me you will be
the foundation of my new home at
Columbia University for you for you it
is a homecoming as well you're the first
graduating class in the program's
history as Mark mentioned to graduate
with the rest of the University and the
rest of the school you are now part of a
larger symbolic home a home that exists
worldwide through our alumni and our
studio x networks and a home on
Morningside Heights that will always
embrace you when you return from your
travels be they from midtown or Michigan
or Mumbai whenever you walk onto this
beautiful campus you should always know
that it defines a place that will be
home for you always and beyond the
symbolism of ceremonies and campuses
this is a homecoming for our entire
program it has been the year in which we
brought the real estate development
program home home to its roots in one of
the best architecture and planning
schools in the world it has been a year
in which we refashion the curriculum
into a structure that reflects
three pillars of entrepreneurial real
estate investment namely an intensive
financial curriculum illegal in
political curriculum and a physical and
technological curriculum that can only
be top tier in a top tier architecture
school on that note has been a year in
which studying the physical side of
development has progressed to the point
where we for the first time as Mark
mentioned launched an experimental
interdisciplinary international effort
to have real estate and architecture
students working together to do
groundbreaking Wharf work in this case
in South Paulo Brazil next year we're
going to look to expand the scope and
the numbers of students in this crazy
experiment with the potential for real
estate projects occurring in Rio de
Janeiro Beijing Mumbai and other
exponentially growing urban laboratories
of the world's fastest-growing economies
as you return year after year or get
occasional email updates about the
constant experiments will be undertaken
here you may be awed by or even
skeptical of the changes that we will be
implementing in your new home such as
the hiring of new faculty the
establishment of a career services
office or creating the new spaces
dedicated to teaching research and
alumni conferences and education in real
estate this is why we implore you to
stay involved as we evolve we welcome
your input as we strive to make your new
home the best place possible housing the
finest real estate development program
in the world and making your great
degree ever more valuable in fact I'm
glad to announce today that in June we
will hire a major branding and graphics
team whose sole mission will be to far
better communicate this extraordinary
program to the industry to prospective
students and employers to alumni and to
the rest of the Academy we will remake
all of our communications collateral
from our website to our brochures to our
social networking media for those of you
who have never heard of the word paper
now I'm betting in the audience there
are parents and other family members who
are thinking of home of their home in a
diff
way they're thinking with this economy
will these kids ever leave my home will
I ever get my study back basically they
want a home leaving not a homecoming
right I am also certainly very
sympathetic with the graduates who think
you know will I be able to build homes
will I be able to afford the home that I
desire as you now leave Colombia you are
in no doubt concerned about the
headwinds before you these are
challenging times but for most
indications the worst is passing for
those of you who've still been
unsuccessful in your job hunt after all
you can visit Greece this summer for
very little money and when you return
jobs will come I assure you jobs will
come and then a much harder period will
come when you must choose among jobs and
trajectories because you will be among
the most sought-after professionals in
the world whether the recovery is here
or double dips whether we enter our next
big boom period only to crash again over
the longer span of your lives as people
and professionals today's challenges
will gain perspective the relevance of
the crises with the world puts before
you is only meaningful in terms of how
you strategically respond what you learn
and how you grow it is trite but true to
say these are the times that gerdes for
the hard times yet to come and make us
wary when exuberance becomes irrational
and in the end we face far greater
challenges than this particular economic
downturn the challenge world you now
enter is also your new home and it needs
your stewardship as we've discussed time
and time again our world is growing at a
rapid pace and is witnessing changes
that impact all of us be it oil spills
currency collapses terrorism or health
scares beyond the noise of all of that
I've tried to impress upon you what I
believe to be the central challenge of
our times the challenge that led me to
the profession the challenge that will
inform all that you do and that
challenge simply put is growth our world
is careening towards a population of 9
billion people by 2050 and with
widespread poverty on the deck
fine that's poverty on the decline in
countries like Brazil India and China we
are facing a prosperous urban growth
curve that will be built by a massive
growing real estate industry worldwide
in many ways that is very good news for
us how we as Americans and New Yorkers
compete is a different question how do
we build what the prosperous world is
seeking which are dense green buildings
and skyscrapers with modern
infrastructure and attractive urban
environments that serve them this will
be the central challenge of our
teetering tax base are murky political
system and our very way of life and as
we look nationwide at a failing suburban
landscape as we look at Phoenix and
Vegas and exurban California we realize
that these sprawling locations unlike
our most dense cities are experiencing
much higher rates of foreclosure much
higher rates of unemployment much higher
rates of energy use and even much higher
rates of obesity as our health care
costs skyrocket we must confront the
challenge of how we build a smarter
nation in a more prosperous more
competitive more crowded world and we as
developers should lead and prosper from
that discussion the vast majority of you
will go out and build cities to be sure
planners may plan them architects may
design them bankers may finance them but
you are the builders of tomorrow and as
such with that comes a responsibility a
special compact with the world as job
opportunities expand some of you may be
tempted to build more sprawl more
cul-de-sacs more strip malls that render
all of our countryside banal our economy
vulnerable and your own investment shaky
instead consider a different path one
that breaks from that herd and leads to
more success because it mirrors the
demographic trends of this world the
hard skills you learned here will be
crucial for such decisions but far more
significant will be whether we taught
you the critical thinking it takes to
see value where no one else sees value
this is of course the hallmark of men
like mark holiday Steve Roth Steven wish
and John mechanic
all of whom spoke to us this semester
about breaking from the herd to create
value for their cities and for
themselves consider when Mark holiday
told us of a shift away from Class B
suburban office product to class a urban
office product a shift that has not only
led to great success for him but led to
a better city in a better world I can
therefore think of no better way to
close our years together than with a
keynote address from my friend Mary and
I who has built one of the most
successful careers in this industry by
continuously breaking from the herd by
bringing fresh ideas to her clients and
her city and being a parent and by being
a paragon of integrity in a world in
which Trust is the essential commodity
The Wall Street Journal has written
there is an exceedingly small club of
women who have managed to move to the
top that clubs most prominent members
Mary untie the New York Observer just
named her the seventh most powerful real
estate executive in the city crain's new
york business has named Mary Ann the
third most powerful businesswoman across
all industries in New York City and the
New York Post placed her number four on
their most influential women in New York
list saying New York New York it's her
kind of town literally indeed it is from
the revitalization of times square and
the rebirth of downtown to the westward
expansion of Midtown central business
district Mary Ann has been at the
forefront of the transformation of New
York skyline during her 26 years in the
real estate industry she has been
responsible for a staggering 70 4.5
million square feet of commercial
transactions and her deals have anchored
more than 6.2 million square feet of new
construction in New York believed to be
a record in commercial brokerage Mary
Ann has been CEO of CBRE's New York
tri-state region since 2002 on january
first of this year she was also named
chairman of the real estate board of New
York the first woman to hold this
position in revenues 114 year history
cementing her role as a thought leader
in our profession I could go on and on
about Mary Ann's list of accomplishments
as well as her own life story because
they're so compelling when I called her
and asked if she would grace us here
today she immediately accepted
actually in about 25 seconds it was
amazing and I knew then we would get the
best advice to inspire you and to guide
you as you go into those headwinds I'm
also thrilled to announce here today for
the first time that Marianne has agreed
to serve on our newly formed industry
industry advisory board which will be
chaired by mark holiday and will as an
elite ten to twelve member body of the
most senior development leadership in
this city provide us with the unwavering
guidance we need as we navigate into the
future so Marianne for you as well this
is a homecoming in closing before I ask
Marianne to take the podium I ask that
after you leave this cut at campus you
come home often come back with stories
of how you like Marianne are helping to
build a better city and a better world a
world that is not the joyride of earlier
of this decade but instead is the world
that makes your family your University
in yourselves proud about the lasting
value that you will continue to create
congratulations ladies and gentlemen go
get them I give you Mary anti thanks
I am so honored to be here with you
today first of all congratulations to
all of you by virtue of your selection
by and graduation from Columbia you were
among the best and brightest in our
field but I'm also delighted to speak to
speak with you and clearly one of the
reasons I so readily said yes because it
is very rare to get the chance to speak
to ninety two lucky people
simultaneously and I I believe in luck
just the way I believe in perfect pitch
or great hand-eye coordination or any of
those other unquantifiable but
absolutely real traits that the truly
gifted possess Napoleon said that luck
was one of the two most important
qualities he sought in a general if you
want to know the second one when I see
you at the faculty building later on you
can ask me what it is but why do I want
to be around lucky people and that's a
silly question and since you all now
have master's degrees from Columbia you
already know the answer always seek the
company of lucky people because maybe it
will be contagious so why are you lucky
first you are so lucky to have been in
graduate school during the great
recession
I know those of you who haven't landed a
job yet maybe you possibly don't see the
benefit of emerging from graduate school
in the aftermath of a financial
Cataclysm but trust me on this getting
hired today is much better than getting
hired in the later stages of an upcycled
today you have the wind at your back and
by the time the next downturn comes and
you know it inevitably will come you
will have bargained built financed and
earned your way to a real estate track
record the Great Recession has given
your career room to run another benefit
of all recessions is that such moments
disturb the natural order of things and
where there is disorder there is
opportunity in my own career I have
found the greatest achievement in
disarray I always loved Martha Graham
you know the dancer choreographer
statement she said fewer horses run well
on a muddy track then too it's hard to
learn skepticism in a bull market but
the committed belief that something can
go wrong in a deal is a key to lasting
success in our business probably in any
business optimism gets you into deals
but its skepticism that will enable you
to come out of success on the other side
when the market is on a tear it's very
easy to believe and believe me I've
heard this repeatedly there's a new
paradigm or whatever the catch phrase of
a moment is to deny the inherent
cyclicality of real estate but if you
are fortunate enough to enter the real
estate industry in a down cycle as I did
you will find that a suspicion of
euphoric eyes stays with you forever and
it will serve you well of course you're
lucky because you got into Columbia and
got training at a great institution in a
great city two things at Columbia and
New York City have in common an
insistence on excellence and a ready
embrace of talent at Columbia as VaShawn
was saying
you had extraordinary access to our
industry's best professionals and that
exposure to deep and crafty real estate
thinkers people who are able to execute
their ideas that exposure is precious I
promise you that in the midst of a
problem and by the way the surefire way
to know that you're advancing in your
career is when more and more problems
keep coming to you till finally one day
you reach a point where the only thing
that ever comes to you is problems and
requests for charitable contributions
and then you will know you've arrived at
a certain place but anyway whenever you
are in the midst of a problem you will
recall some pearl from mark holiday or
Steve Roth or any of the other industry
leaders with whom you studied and that
pearl will be to use a Harry Potter term
in this place is reminded me of harry
potter from the moment I walked in to
use the Harry Potter term it will be the
portkey that leads you through the maze
coming out of Columbia are also going to
be among the first real estate
professionals to engage our business
from a global perspective the day-to-day
reality of real estate remains local
local local but the capital and the
competition is now global as is the
universe of best practices and good
ideas and the talent that travels with
it your luck also resides as you Sean
said in the projections on New York City
the nation and global population growth
if you're in the business of housing
people and giving them venues to work
play and shop then there's nothing
sweeter than the momentum created by
favorable demographics how fortunate for
you that exponential population growth
will make our industry more relevant in
the coming decades and more challenging
finally you are so lucky because you
have command of technology and ours is a
business that has been and will continue
to be transformed by technology in so
many of its manifestations whether it's
virtual design deliver delivery from the
building modeling Building Information
modelling to the role of social
networking
and marketing and by the way very
practical technology will give you
access to the senior levels of whatever
firm hires you you want to be the go-to
guy for somebody at your new place of a
business just become his or her
technology coach do it with respect
obviously you don't want to say what you
did what do it with charm and above all
do it with relevance I promise you it
will be a winning asset trade so your
new career is born under a lucky star
how do you convert that favorable augury
into success in real estate in my
experience you need three things to
succeed in real estate expertise
resources and power now i'm betting
looking at you all that you're filled
with expertise at this moment and that
you don't have a whole bunch of
resources unless you will come from
private wealth and you probably have no
power in real estate but I maybe I may
be too pessimistic on this so don't take
it the wrong way certainly your Columbia
experience alone has given you an ample
supply of expertise and my only advice
here is as soon as is practicable make
yourself the master of one small piece
of our industry no matter how arcane
it's been my experience that real estate
invariably rewards mastery and once the
word gets out that you know this subject
index I promise you opportunity will
knock at your door now I do want to say
one cautionary note on this and I'm
going to draw from a personal non real
estate example you just should be
careful of the subject you pick to
master my husband is a plastic surgeon
and he began his career as a
reconstructive surgeon and as a resident
he set out to make himself the authority
on just one subject he needed something
complex so that he could demonstrate his
sophisticated grasp of anatomy and he
also needed a topic that hadn't been
exhausted in the literature so he picked
the bottom of the
now this is really a tough subject okay
it's an area that's packed with nerve
endings it's really a minefield for a
surgeon and anybody who's ever had
problems with their feet knows that this
is not a simple subject I can tell you
the good news my husband David succeeded
his articles were published in all the
leading journals he got to speak at all
the big conferences he got called upon
for all manner of things but the bad
news was he was famous for being an
expert on the bottom of the foot so my
only take home point is when you pick
your area of mastery just have it in
your head don't pick the bottom of the
foot okay as for resources unless you
were born to wealth you are reliant on
the resources of your employer
interestingly enough I've come to
believe that expertise and power are
much more important than resources which
I know seems like a counterintuitive
thought because you can't really
accomplish anything without resources
however if the expertise is there and it
is accompanied by power resources will
find their way to your project now I'm a
little concerned that this may only be a
Manhattan perspective because i'm going
to give an example from our firm every
so often our investment sales department
sends out a global email to all of our
people and CB are you there 29,000 of
them worldwide and the email says in
essence the following please stop
sending us people who want to invest in
New York City real estate we are awash
with capital what we need are properties
to sell and this is absolutely the truth
people are always calling up saying I've
got 50 million dollars i'd like to
invest in new york real estate you go ok
that's very exciting do you have any
buildings you'd like to sell the most
recent version of this email was
prompted by an onslaught from global
investors eager to buy distress
manhattan properties the prospects that
there might be bargains out there
somewhere on a Big Apple skyline
produced a deluge of requests but just
as when Christie's or Sotheby's has a
work of art of quality to sell there's
no shortage of buyers for ready ready
buyers from manhattan properties
so the resources component of success is
way more nuanced than this but I do
believe in this simple idea you can
always find resources for the right
product bought at the right price if you
present it to the investor or lender
with the right strategy and the right
financial structure the money is there
power however is the most elusive of all
three of these of these of this triad of
how to succeed in real estate it's also
the one that's hard as to quantify
except that you know it when it's there
people tend to be very uncomfortable
with this word and I think especially
women its associated with aggression
with egotism with the manipulative use
of others and in real estate it is all
those things and more power is also the
essential ingredient of success in our
industry but today I'm speaking of it
only in the most positive sense and I'm
going to define it the Wayne at owings
of skidmore owings merrill to find it
when he spoke of it as the fifth
dimension of planning the art of getting
things done at the end of the day power
and real estate is the ability to
transform expertise and resources into a
done deal bringing your project to
successful conclusion once you
demonstrate you possess this capacity
your career has momentum and believe me
with momentum everything is easier so
how do you build a powerful career trust
Sean said it trust is a starting point
the gap between idea and execution can
only be filled by a series of
individuals acting either sequentially
or in concert who've elected to trust
you the seller who believes you'll close
the deal the investors and lenders who
put up the money the government
officials who sign on the condo buyer
who puts up the deposit the tenant who
executes solis each of them is making a
bet that you'll succeed and their
collective waiver on your wager on your
success is because they trust you can
deliver whenever I show a prospective
tenant a rendering of a newer remodel
building
I reflect on the leap I am asking them
to make I'm asking them to bet their
company's ability to operate and their
firms balance sheet that this glossy
fantasy that I'm showing them will
materialize as promised only trust makes
that possible how do you build trust in
a professional sense now we all know the
personal characteristics that are
components of trust honesty reliability
fairness these are behaviors that over
time and gender trust among people but
in a curious way the standard for
trustworthy conduct in a professional
sense is more elastic I'm sure you're
not going to be surprised to hear that
there are powerful people in real estate
who aren't Paragons of honesty or
reliability or who don't play fair now
I'm a Catholic schoolgirl and believe it
or not it came as a shock to me that
there is a continuum in assessing
honesty in business I always thought
honestly was binary it was true or it
was false but time has taught me how
broad a range of spectrum there is on
personal qualities and time has also
taught me that if you come up short on
the three qualities that underpin
success your power will be less and it
will be power that was costly to acquire
and really costly to hold on to your
buildings will lease more slowly and in
some cases the only gonna lease in a
superheated market no one will sell you
an off-market deal you'll be in constant
quest for new naive lenders and
investors and you'll be denied one of
the sweetest parts of a real estate
career long trusted relationships that
blossom into friendships people are at
the heart of power and given the
complexity of 20th century a 21st
century real estate the need for a
diverse professional network is a key to
success obviously you have the
beginnings of that network in your very
class right here but here I urge you to
do something that's very hard and
true for people to do and to me in large
measure account for why more people
don't succeed in the development world
I'm asking you not to default to your
comfort zone when picking your alliances
so often I see people making comfy
decisions about their team members
because of their bias in favor of
loyalty and against confrontation I wish
I had a dollar for every time someone
said or implied I pick Joe because he
always has my back that criteria is
perfect for friendship and its really
bad for business if you want to be
effective to execute on your plans you
need to be analytical about the skills
required to get from here to there and
you need to be relentless in your quest
for the right colleagues we don't learn
by staring in the mirror it's
differences that stimulate ideas two of
the best people decisions I've seen in
recent real estate history involve
powerful leaders acknowledging gaps in
their own skill set and hiring to fill
those gaps typically I don't think any
of us associate Steve green or Steve
Roth with personal humility these are
just not traits that spring to mind when
you think of them yet both of them made
a brilliant hire based on a candid self
appraisal of what they needed to ratchet
their company up to an even higher level
Steve green made mark holidays CEO of
his company when Mark was 37 years old I
went to the party that Steve gave to
celebrate marks appointment and at the
party I was remember this moment I said
to Steve why did you do this now you're
not so old and he's really young what
made you decide to make him CEO at this
moment and Steve green said to me if I
didn't do this now I was in danger of
losing mark because I know there'll be
opportunities for him and I know that
mark can take us beyond where i can take
this firm on its own and how right that
was similarly when Steve Roth's reason
for hiring Mike facility was based on a
recognition of his own limitations
Steve will tell you that he hired Mike
because Mike convinced him to pay up for
properties Steve Roth is a brilliant
negotiator but he always had trouble
when he didn't feel that he was stealing
a deal with vas analysis absolutely true
believe me with fascitelli Roth was able
to make fascitelli made Roth understand
that somehow paying full market price
today might be exactly the right way to
build vornado and again that's exactly
what happened the whole Penn Plaza
dynamic was all fascitelli another part
of the people in power equation involves
engagement with a larger community this
is very hard I think for people who are
starting out to realize but the most
pervasive failing I find among
professionals is the naive belief that
if you're working hard and you're doing
a good job that's going to lead to
success in and of itself certainly you
have to have focus you have to have
diligence you obviously have expertise
and those are all prerequisites but it's
important to look away from the computer
screen now and again and engage the
larger community ours is a unique
business in that it is grounded in the
community we're the only industry that
can't say you know what taxes are too
high we're moving to somewhere else if
we're going to do our business we're
going to do it here or whatever
community you elect to engage in real
estate development in if you are working
in real estate or in a city or town you
owe that community the benefit of your
energy in order to build it into a
better place and while this is good
citizenship trust me it is good business
to there an infinite number of ways to
do this I urge you to pick your spot
pick it early for me it was the real
estate board of New York and it has been
one place where I can engage the full
dynamics of the real estate in the city
and over the years I have come to know
colleagues in every aspect of real
estate in this area and end government
officials as well and you have to
believe me this wide-ranging network of
friendships makes every endeavor I
undertake in our business that much
easier
one more thought there's a time-tested
shortcut to power in any business
finding the right mentor nothing pulls
you up the power curve faster gets you
to the table sooner or helps you bypass
and stakes more often than a first-rate
mentor however you will not find a
mentor by asking for one don't send an
email to the mentor of your choice and
invite him or her for a cup of coffee by
definition anyone worth having as a
mentor is busy and unless you have
something to offer them you are just
wasting their time and yours this is
where engagement in the larger community
comes in if you're chosen mentor sees
you on the playing field committing your
time showing good judgment placing your
energy well your chance of coming into
this individuals sphere is that much
greater and it certainly makes the
connection that much deeper so last
thought before sending you off into the
real estate world to make magic it's
been said that the key to a happy life
is work worth doing that you have do it
well
well I'm afraid we cannot do the
visiting speaker at graduation anymore
everybody would look just terrible there
was magnificent I just can't help but
react one of my great mentors has been
exactly mark holiday and not by accident
vision is the first mark holiday
professor and director of the real
estate program and I can't remember how
it happened i'm trying to think now did
i call him and ask for coffee i don't
think so i think we found ourselves side
by side and when Mark holiday who is as
sharp as can be decided to literally
invest in the future of his own program
this was a decision made with all of the
firepower of every other decision he's
made and so when we hired be shown in
that name the pressure was on the sean
has managed to survive along seven
months but we're still watching he's
doing a great job me sean is going to
continue the way in which he's honoring
mike holidays extraordinary generosity
and leadership by reading the names of
the successful victims of his program
shanna and myself and Hank Bell are
going to shake the hands of absolutely
everybody right okay thank you so much
and I also have to stop and thank Mary
Ann that was just extraordinary and I
really hope those words sank in and stay
with you always so we are going to now
confer the degrees there is this
rotational system so one row at a time
please right we're going to take a
photograph and then i'm going to start
reading the names jonathan agree lius
owner I can sell
lurch of it as a venir in them
Laura Barnhart
Jonah belkin lafa biscotto Jesse beagle
Peter bridgeman
thomas burns
Jose past amante
drew Butler fan club Lin Chi Owen
Callahan
spero Cantonese
yawn tell Carter
Adam Cassidy
dorks ln
ja yang Cheng
ingrid che
samaire shake
charlita chong
Michael chow
Tyler Cooper
Clifford corral
Millicent katoh
Chris on Elba tall oh I'm sorry did it
oh sorry ro Elom sorry he looks like
houssam Joaquin Fernandez turns
David fine Hirsch
Alex Foster
Gabby Franco
Luis Gimbert olio
Adam ganser
Anna Gill cough stock
Brian graybill
chase Grayson
natalia guzman
Angela Harris
Matt Hopkins
Philip hosford
all right we need who oh sorry Miriam
Tuffy
Brandon Jones
han Kim
samuel clap
Christopher kosonen
George canarian
rakesh la la
enrique Lara
Montiel are gay
Hannah Leonard
mikhail levy
this Matthew Levine
Miriam link
David lubin
thomas loosen
Eduardo Missy's
allarde badani
I want to miss you peaks Daniel
mandelbaum
Edward McGrath
rajmata
Dominique Miller
Sean mirza
John Moran
jose moreno
Charles Musgrave
Jeremy Orlin
chianti park
Ryan park
Andrew Pearson
aditi Aram
president Brett Raskin
Gregory Richards
leash a FLIR
Brian share
Michael safan tests
David trow
Keith Smith
Bryan Stevenson
frampton Swan
Brian tauber okey oh sorry miss one Paul
tartar sorry Paul
joseph taylor
Ashley taro
Christine tongue
Alexandra's Julius
rusty Van Zant
Darren vest
max Wong
graduate a new father Tyler Williams
which coos Chiana Joshua woodberry
David's Oberg
and last but not least my clothes Iseman
so this is the real estate development
class of 2010
yes we do have some fries
well there are a few prizes so I'm now
going to introduce and I apologize to
anyone's name i mispronounced I have
been a victim of that I know you'll find
that a surprise with the last name like
chakravarthi but people have slaughtered
my name in the past so I apologize if I
done that I now would like to introduce
professor emeritus Hank fell a man who
needs no introduction the person who
continuously is always brought up every
alumnus I talked to is the most
influential professor they have in their
career here we're very honored to have
Hank bell here tonight to give out the
awards thank
the William kidney fellows memorial
traveling prize it goes to John Moran
and leash a flaw
the school leavers
the school-wide Committee on fellowships
and awards micro brow and Monty lodge
the next one I get to shake the hand the
Hank Bell entrepreneurial award goes to
Brian Grable
the Oxford prize cliff corral and Jonna
Jonah Belton
you
next the waters in recognition of the
well researched and crafted thesis green
real estate evaluating private equity
investment opportunity tom lucid
the next the service awards for
outstanding service to the school Angela
Harris
a repeat performance Jonah Belkin
joakim Fernandez turns
next is the vision and real estate award
in recognition of her creativity and
commitment to visioning and development
class case studies Winnie hung
now for the what I consider very special
despite the scholastic performance for a
very highest academic performance in the
class crisco Sonnen
we're not done yet Gregory Richards
and last but not least Peter bridgeman
you know it's an amazing moment let me
tell you about real estate handshakes I
don't know if you have a class on
handshakes but having done about 500
hands today I can tell you that the real
estate program shakes your hand like
things are about to happen and I'm going
to see what I'm going to see a
chiropractor later it's it's a it's a
very special class I mean I think you
have an amazing faculty you have an
amazing director you have a shockingly
good commencement speech unforgettable
and you have the future and that future
is also our future and I just cannot
imagine a more exciting generation more
talented group your multi-dimensional
missiles you're absolutely trouble
you're big-time trouble I think this is
a new generation this is a new species
you're going to be the leaders they're
going to be other classes that come
after you they're always going to look
up to you you will not only be the first
of visions classes you're really the
first of this leadership generation a
new form of real estate development a
new kind of partnership new kinds of
collaboration I'm not saying new
paradigm because a lot of what's at the
heart of this is you just hardcore you
just all the way your finance all the
way technology all the way presentation
all the way handshakes all the way
it's an exciting class it's an exciting
time we hope you stay in touch we hope
you stay very close but frankly we're
going to know exactly what you're going
to be doing we're going to know it
because you're going to do very very
bright things and the light from those
things is going to be everywhere all the
time you're provoking a lot of jealousy
in the rest of the school a lot and you
deserve it you totally deserve it this
is the class of 2010
so I just want to close by thanking the
families I know you've had a very long
wet day I've heard a number of future
real estate developers out in the back
of the audience crying a bit they seem
like they're going to be great CEOs
someday the reception and let far be it
from us to stand between you know right
now right here and the party starts at
six-thirty over at faculty house for
those of you don't know where that is
the easiest way to get there is to go
down this gate at 117 street and cut
through sepa the School of International
and public affairs and it's right there
in that courtyard Kyle faculty house
it's on the third floor at six thirty
congratulations to you all it's been a
pleasure to see you here thank you very
much Mary and I for your keynote
commencement speech and we'll see you
over at faculty house your graduated
you